les petits propos ils sont cools aux
siens enroulez avec soin des copeaux de
carottes et procéder avec application au
dressage dans un bol à emporter
décidément la réalité du métier de chef
en temps de pandémie est bouleversée
mais christophe et s'adapte en
conservant la même rigueur
le stress est de dresser dans une boîte
et là pour le coup mais on a une boîte
on a la même surface qu'une assiette
donc voilà on essaie de on essaie de
s'amuser de garder ce lien est d'essayer
de voile a vraiment respecté nos
exigences soit la présentation est
soignée le goût bien entendu à la
hauteur d'un restaurant doublement
étoilé
si les inspecteurs du gault et millau
repassé en plein confinement il ne
regretterai pas l'attribution de ce
titre de cuisinier 2021
basé sur des notes de la saison
précédente en fait on ne cuisine pas que
dans le stress des guidons on cuisine
surtout pour pour les convives pour pour
créer notre maison pour pour avoir ce
lien aussi bien avec notre région aussi
c'est ça qui est super important
les distinctions sont un moteur pour
christophe et mais ils les acceptent en
tant qu'ambassadeur de sa région le val
de loire et ses terres il y a grandi au
sein d'une famille d'agriculteurs et
oeuvrent chaque jour à la valorisation
des produits de son loir-et-cher
n'atteint j'ai connu mes grands parents
dans les années 80 avec les quotas
laitiers à devoir jeter le lait dans les
égouts et ça ça m'a marqué vraiment ça a
marqué mon enfance
et quand je me suis installé à mon
niveau j'ai essayé justement d'aller
chercher tous les petits producteurs
qu'on pouvait avoir autour de nous les
valoriser les mettre en avant et
aujourd'hui ma cuisine elle correspond à
ses terres ligériennes
[Musique]